well uh more now on the 800 000 pound
fine that's been handed down to
Nottingham University Hospital NHS trust
for failings which led to the death of
baby winter Andrews just 23 minutes
after she was born
well joining me now is Donna ockendon
she's chairing the independent review
into Nottingham University Hospitals NHS
trusts maternity Services uh Donna uh
good to see you on Sky News thank you
for joining us I understand that since
you've been conducting this review
You've been contacted by hundreds of
people
um yes we have more than 900 families
from across Nottinghamshire um have
contacted the review directly and I
should also add that more than 400
members of Staff nuh Nottingham staff in
and around maternity Services have also
made contact with us
and the sort of failings that the judge
was highlighting in the case of winter
Andrew is a catalog of failings uh she
said what are the ones that concern you
most and what are you seeing widespread
instances of
so we're at the very earliest stage of
our review we only started um the review
officially on the 1st of September so
it's too early yet
um to be able to
um you know draw any um conclusions or
put together anything around any
patterns
um I have had the privilege of meeting
with Sarah and Gary Andrews and I know
um of their story and I I think for me
what I'd like to stress is the absolute
tragedy that has befallen this little
family and they were in a position where
they had to bury
um their newborn daughter rather than
bring her home she should be playing
with her little brother now she isn't
and nothing can ever take away their
grief and their anguish
and I know um obviously the you're still
at the early stages as you say of this
review the hospital
um has said yes you know we we own up to
these failings
um since
what happened to the Andrews have
changes already been made should women
who are about to go and have their
babies feel like it's going to be safe
um yes the trusts are working really
hard on their maternity Improvement plan
and what I also want to say to women in
and around Nottingham today is that as
we find issues that need improving
um learning for the trust we will be
sharing that with the trust in real time
I don't want women to be worried and
thinking oh well Don is going to tell
the trust in 18 months time that there's
loads of things that they have to do we
won't do that we will share those
improvements in real time and so that
the trust can continually
improve and which clearly they they must
do
um prosecution prosecutions against NHS
trusts are rare
um why when there are systemic problems
in hospitals is it particularly acute in
maternity units because we've seen it
before
so I I think that it is fair to say that
generally the NHS across England is a
very very safe place to have a baby
however we do know that things go wrong
you will know that I chaired um the
wide-ranging review Into the Shrewsbury
and Telford Hospital NHS trust and we've
had the findings from East Kent too and
of course Morgan Bay in in 2015.
um there needs to be more done to
improve Staffing across maternity
services and by that we know that we're
more than 2 000 midwives short but of
course the maternity team is made up of
anesthetist Obstetricians neonatologists
and so on and I talk to those team
members across England pretty much every
day of the week and what they say to me
is is they are often overworked on their
knees giving of their very best
um but sometimes their very best isn't
enough we we know from the select
committee report the House of Commons
select committee report
in June of 2021 I believe that there
needed to be very significant funding
increases immediately and that select
committee said and of course although
some of that money has been forthcoming
we're still in the situation where we
are short on the ground every day in
many maternity units of key staff
yeah and and to the extent that that was
flagged as a major failing in the in the
Andrews case under Staffing
um what are hospitals to do should they
be turning women who need to give birth
away
so I I think that on a daily basis the
maternity leadership team will be
looking
um at the work that needs to be done
we'll be dealing
um as safely as they can with the women
that come through the doors I often
think of
um you know maternity Services as its
own women's a e Department you can't
predict your work from hour to hour from
minute to minute
um I'm confident that maternity leaders
are giving of their very best in the
rare cases when a unit needs to close
because they simply do not have the
workforce to deal with the you know an
increasing workload there is a very
strict protocol that is in place around
communicating
um with other units but I think it's
fair to say that you know maternity
units are prioritizing on an ongoing
basis
right Donna ockington uh good to talk to
you thank you very much
thank you